- I remember my step dad,
or like my mom's boyfriend or whatever,
- This dude, he was like a
mean old biker dude, you know?
And he used to, like, he
used to make, make us, like
when we fucked up, you know,
he would come in the room
with a loaded 12-gauge Mossberg
and he'd rack all the shelves out of it.
And he make us hold the
fucking shotgun like this
and stand on our tippy-toes.
And like, when we started buckling
he would whip us and shit, you know
he'd put guns to our head and
all kinds of shit, you know.
- [Interviewer] This was
one of your dad's friends?
- Yeah, it actually was.
But my mom ended up like
being with them, you know?
- [Interviewer] Oh wow.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So David,
you, you grew up where?
- At Whittier.
- [Interviewer] Whittier.
- I was born in Wittier hospital.
- [Interviewer] A suburb of LA East,
East side of LA
- [David] Southeast.
- [Interviewer] Southeast.
And tell me about your family.
You, you grew up with two parents.
- Yeah, my mom and my dad, but I mean
and when I was about four years old
my dad ended up catching
the death penalty for,
he murdered my next door neighbors,
as crazy as that might sound.
But he's, he was real like
strung out on dope you know?
Mostly they speed
heroin, cocaine, you know
speed balling and stuff.
And I guess one night he broke
into my neighbor's house,
two elderly people and he
butchered him, you know
stabbed them each like 40 something times
and bashed their heads in
with like blunt force injuries
or whatever it was, you know?
And, but yeah, he went to prison.
- [Interviewer] So your dad
murdered the next door neighbor?
- Yeah. Two of 'em. Two elderly people.
- [Interviewer] Two elderly people.
- Yeah. And yeah, and I was
asleep next door you know.
- [Interviewer] You were how old?
- Four.
- [Interviewer] You were four years old.
Do you remember this?
- I remember coming home.
And about a week later they
found the bodies, you know.
And I remember coming home
and it was all taped off
and there was all kinds
of police cars and we're
we had our little McDonald's
happy meals, you know.
I remember they kind of like rushed us to
you know, rush my mom,
like, Hey, where's Larry
Where's Larry, you know.
We're looking for Larry.
We needed to see Larry.
That's my dad.
- [Interviewer] Larry's your dad?
Yeah. That's pretty much all
I remember of that, you know.
- [Interviewer] So your
dad, was he convicted?
- Oh yeah. He was convicted.
He was actually given a judgment of death
on November 4th, 1987, which
happened to be my birthday.
- [Interviewer] So your
dad got the death penalty
on your birthday?
- On my birthday.
Yes. Yes he did.
I never went to go see him or nothing
but I used to write him
once in a while, you know.
- [Interviewer] What's it like growing up
with a dad who was on death row?
- It's it's life changing.
I think, you know, I think
it's a milestone, you know.
I lived in, I lived in a house
up to like off and on until
a couple of years ago.
- [Interviewer] So you guys
live in the same house?
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] After that.
We stayed there, you know
and it was actually my grandma's
house, but me and my mom
and brother and my sister, we
all stayed there, you know?
Yeah. Sometimes, me and my
brother would be walking
down the street and people
would be going out the door.
Hey, you gonna be just
like your dad, you know.
We're like, Hey fuck you, you know?
What are you talking about you know?
- [Interviewer] Wow.
But yeah.
- [Interviewer] Well, I mean, so
your dad got the death penalty and
is he's gone now?
- He actually died.
They actually overturned his
his death sentence in
like 2005, I believe.
But that's because they
failed to like bring
up the fact that he was
abused as a child, you know
and they overturned it and gave
him life without, you know.
- [Interviewer] Oh is that right?
So he did not end up dying.
- He got off, he got off of death row
but they just put them in
a regular prison, you know.
So to him it was like
being freed and you know,
- [Interviewer] And
then he, he passed away?
- Yeah. He passed away
about two years ago.
Yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So he,
his abuse, his, his child
his childhood was?
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about
that. What you know of it.
- I only know of it from reading, reading
you know, Google, whatever, you know
his whole transcripts or whatever it is.
Yeah. I guess he was, he
was born out of wedlock.
So they, they, they
singled him out, you know
and they would burn,
burn him with cigarettes
and feed him scraps and sit
and send him to school
in like tattered clothes
and make him sleep outside
on like a box spring
and lock him in closets, all
that crazy stuff, you know?
And they would like give
him up to the system
and he was sent to like these, these like
orphanages or whatever it is, you know,
or they sexually abused him
and physically abused him and
everything else, you know?
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So his
childhood sounds horrible.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And then
how was your childhood?
- My childhood was, it was,
it was different, you know
because my mom ended up like
being with somebody else.
It was like a crazy biker dude, you know?
And
- [Interviewer] So let's
go back a bit to your dad.
So your dad murdered
the next door neighbor.
What were the circumstances around that?
- Circumstances were just the fact
that I believe he was just out of his mind
from doing drugs.
- [Interviewer] Which drugs?
- Heroin, cocaine, speed.
And he would do like speed
balls and stuff, you know
and I dunno what possessed him to
break into my neighbor's
house and, you know,
steal some stuff from
some old people, you know,
an elderly couple
but he ended up stabbing
them both to death.
- [Interviewer] So just a drug?
- Drug binge thing.
Or I don't know, I believe
he described it as a
he didn't know what he was doing.
It was like these little
figures coming at him
or something like that,
you know, but I mean
I'm sure he was conscious of
what he was doing you know.
- [Interviewer] Did your
dad have that personality
of somebody who was violent or?
- I, I only have good
memories of my dad, you know
I don't have no bad memories
of my dad at all, you know?
- [Interviewer] Okay. So,
so now your childhood?
- My child was, was
it was a little rough off
and on, you know, I would
I was always in trouble,
you know, at school
you know, like shit, from
kindergarten, from preschool up
I would always get kicked out
of school, you know, started
started doing dope
around like 13 years old.
And I was sent to like programs, you know
or we call that like
residential programs or whatever
you know, for kids that are
fucked up, you know, bad
til I was about 17 and, you
know, and they let me out.
And that's when I started doing more dope
you know, speed, mostly, you know, my
my family got kind of tired of that
and kicked me out, you know?
So I was homeless when
I was only 17 years old
running around the streets, you know
just getting high stealing shit, you know
gang banging you know.
- [Interviewer] So you were in gangs.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Which gang were you in?
Cause you're, you're, you're a Caucasian.
- Yeah. I was, I was from a Hispanic gang.
- [Interviewer] Whittier
is mostly Hispanic?
- Yeah. Where your gang, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Actually one of my, my
homeboys from my neighborhood
actually jumped me in to my neighborhood,
was actually stab, ended
up stabbing me 18 times
hitting me in the head
with the hammer, you know
- [Interviewer] The scar
on your forehead is?
- Yeah. Yeah, he hit me, he came over
and he just asked me for
a shot of dope, you know?
And I was like, all right. Yeah sure.
Come in, you know?
Yeah. I see nothing coming.
And all of a sudden, he just, I was making
out his dope and he, he
asked me for it already.
He picked up a hammer.
He said, this is a nice hammer.
And he just cracked me with the hammer.
I flew over the bed.
I had a little baby, like
right next to me, you know, my
my girlfriend's baby was
only eight months old.
You know, he was right next to me.
And he hits me with this
hammer and I fly over the bed.
And he just started stabbing me, you know
for no reason whatsoever.
And one way or another, I made it out
and made it to my neighbor's house.
And actually the same, I
got collapsed on the same
the same house that my dad
murdered my neighbors, you know?
So I thought I was gonna die
right there on their steps
but I ended up living,
they air lifted me to the
US, USC, or one of
those places, UC Irvine,
they air lifted me to UC
Irvine and saved my life.
And pretty much after that, I didn't have
I had no like no direction, you know
I wanted to do something like
I didn't want to be like
that no more, you know?
So my sister brought me down here
to LA mission and that's
how I got down here.
You know, that's how I ended up down here
out downtown LA, you know,
I always thought downtown
LA, fuck that, you know?
I ain't going to downtown.
Hey, you know, it's crazy down
there, you know, but yeah.
I ended up graduating
one of these programs and
but I was strung out the
whole time, you know.
- [Interviewer] So what
is your drug today?
- Fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] Fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] Did you go
from heroin to fentanyl?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I kinda, you know, graduated.
Cause heroin does, it won't
do nothing to me anymore.
Fentanyl's just like this new,
new thing that just came in
you know, like crack, like
hit the eighties, you know
that's what fentanyl is doing, you know?
- [Interviewer] Right.
- To this area.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. A
lot of the heroin addicts
are actually now on Fentanyl.
- Yeah. Well, a lot of
people like heroin only
and then a lot of people
like Fentanyl only.
And it's just, I guess
it's just their preference.
You know, a lot of people
are afraid of fentanyl.
I've seen a lot of people OD on Fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] Have you ODed?
- I have not ODed on Fentanyl or anything,
but I brought people back like
about at least five people
back from ODing you know.
An ex girlfriend.
She, she ODed on me in my house,
a friend the other day just
ODed on me in my house.
A couple other people, but I
always had like Narcan on me
you know?
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
So when you say in your
house, were you in a tent or?
I live in my SRO now.
- [Interviewer] Oh you are, okay.
- Yeah.
I live right here on, at the Roslyn.
- [Interviewer] You do?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I finally got housing and stuff, you know.
- [Interviewer] How'd you
get housing being an addict?
'Cause usually the
addicts don't get housing.
- Yeah. Well, cause I graduated
the program here, you know?
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
And I told them, I need housing, you know.
I graduated this program. You
guys got to get me housing.
Yeah. And you don't give
me housing, but I mean
all those people in the SRO's are just
they're all getting high and shit too.
You know, I just, I believe
that people are here
they live in the tents and stuff.
It's just like, they choose to like
like live in these tents,
you know what I mean?
Cause they, they like, you
know, the lifestyle, you know
selling dope, getting high,
not having to pay rent.
You know what I mean?
But yeah.
- [Interviewer] So do you,
what do you do for money?
- I'm on SSI.
I got SSI from, from when I got stabbed.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
- Yeah, PTSD. And so yeah, I'm on SSI.
I get a check for like about $945 a month.
I live off of that.
- [Interviewer] Do you, do you feel
like somehow you're following
your dad's footsteps?
Not that you're murdering
anybody, but just drug use?
- Definitely. Definitely.
It definitely was like a
milestone in my life, you know.
If that wouldn't have
happened, I believe I'd just
you know, being a ordinary, you know,
suburb kid, you know?
I don't think I'd be in
downtown LA right now, you know.
But yeah, growing up like that, it was
it was definitely a
life changer, you know?
- [Interviewer] Did you
have kids of your own?
- I do. I have a little girl.
- [Interviewer] And where is she?
She's my, my sister adopted her.
She's, she's 10 now.
She just turned to ten the other day,
but I don't have custody of
her or nothing, but yeah.
- [Interviewer] So where
do you think your life
goes from here?
- From here?
- [Interviewer] Being a
fentanyl addict is it's
tough to snipe out over.
- Yeah.
I know it is, but it's all
about choices, you know?
I believe that either
I'll snap out of it or
I don't know.
I really couldn't tell, you
know, since my life is just
it takes all kinds of
weird turns, you know?
- [Interviewer] I'm sure it does.
- You know, but I mean
I'm just trying to keep my
head above water right now
you know?
Basically.
- [Interviewer] What
with the dad who murders
the next door neighbors at four years old.
You're destined to have some
unique struggles, right?
- Yeah definitely.
Even my brother, you know, like he's
he's a little different too, you know?
But he's
- [Interviewer] Tell
me about your siblings.
- My brother? Well, my
sister actually came out.
She was like the most normal one, you know
she don't do drugs and she went to school.
She has a good job and stuff, you know
but my brother is just like
me, he runs the streets,
sells dope. Does dope,
you know, steals shit and
you know, hustles.
You know? Pretty much same shit as me.
He just doesn't do it down here.
He does it in Long Beach.
You know?
- [Interviewer] So you have
some other interesting scars
on your body.
- Oh yeah.
This is from getting stabbed right here.
This from getting stabbed.
I got hit in my lung and my colon.
This is a, scars on my chest when this
dude tried to carve out my heart.
- [Interviewer] What does that mean?
- This is from when I got stabbed
- [Interviewer] It's the heart surgery?
- No, no, this is when I
got stabbed from the dude.
- [Interviewer] Oh, what is
the big one on your stomach?
- This if from 'cause
I got hit in my colon
when he stabbed me.
He had to open me up.
- [Interviewer] Oh so
that's from the doctor.
- Yeah. This one, right here
is from, from heart surgery
'cause I got endocarditis, endocarditis
from slamming bad, dope
down here, you know?
- [Interviewer] You
feel lucky to be alive?
- Yeah. Yeah, definitely.
I definitely got a couple
of chances, you know.
I hope I'm not blowing it, you know, but
- [Interviewer] All right David.
Thank you for sharing your unique story.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And good
luck with your addiction.
- All right.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.